estas son sólo algunas de las muchas
edificaciones civiles que han sido
atacadas en slogans
están en frente de donde beatle y su
madre recolectan agua dos veces al día
desde hace semanas los acueductos
quedaron dañados y si los combates van a
venir cerca nos iremos para nosotros la
vida todavía está bien
la mujer muestra el horno de leña en el
que cocinan en el jardín debido a los
cortes frecuentes de electricidad
como muchos otros esta familia piensa
que posiblemente tendrán que irse el
invierno si no los expulsa la batalla
que cada vez se siente más cerca si lo
harán la falta de agua gas y
electricidad
maarten distribuye medicinas y comida
entre más de 40 mil personas que
permanecen en el globo antes muchos de
ellos han regresado después de cinco
meses de guerra muchos ahora vamos a
donde una mujer que necesite alguna
medicina es una medicina necesaria para
salvar la vida de una persona la mayoría
de las farmacias están cerradas nadie
las abastece
nombre yo hablé cal
we had mínimos no nos podemos ir bajo
estas condiciones primero tenemos
problemas con la salud y segundo no
tenemos adónde ir
muchos de los que se han quedado son
personas mayores o quienes los cuidan
cheste más ataques y bombardeos de todo
tipo incluidos aéreos cada vez es más
difícil manejar y entregar esto y
otros más jóvenes lo hacen para proteger
sus viviendas de posibles robos este es
el caso de basile
cada cierto tiempo tengo miedo
especialmente cuando disparan tengo
miedo de dejar el corredor cuando atacan
fáciles reconoce que la población ha
aprendido a vivir con la amenaza de los
ataques las alarmas ya hacen parte de la
vida diaria pocos corren a esconderse
esta mañana la doctora valentina va a
visitar a un recién nacido el tercero en
una semana todavía le sorprende que las
mujeres embarazadas se queden en la
ciudad william me pregunto por qué no se
han ido las miro con mucha curiosidad
porque me causa gran sorpresa que
mujeres embarazadas no se vayan en mi
mensaje
asegura que seguirá trabajando hasta el
día que la vacuna en los militares
aunque todavía espera que ese momento
nunca llegue